الحرب الاوكرانيه على شفا ان تتحول الى
مركز انطلاقي معركه نوويه حقيقيه بين
روسيا من جهه وحلف شمال الاطلسي من جهه
اخرى
[موسيقى]
وفي احدث سيناريوهات التصعيد انضمت
بيلاروسيا حليفه موسكو الى هذا الجدل الذي
بات يقلق العالم بعد موافقتها على استضافه
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه من روسيا
وبحلول يوليو سيكون لموسكو منشاه تخزين
كامله لاسلحه الرعب في هذا البلد المجاور
وفقا للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين تاتي
هذه الخطوه ردا على اعتزام المملكه
المتحده لتزويد كييف باسلحه تحتوي على
اليورانيوم المنظم وهو ما تعهدت موسكو
بالرد عليه
وفي خضم التهديدات المتصاعده بين موسكو
ولندن اكد بوتين ان بلاده لا تنتهكوا اي
التزامات دوليه بشان منع انتشار الاسلحه
النوويه رغم تجميد مشاركتها في معاهده نيو
ستارت التصريحات والاتهامات المتبادله
اعقبتها تحركات حيث قامت روسيا بالفعل
بنقل عشر طائرات قادره على حمل اسلحه
نوويه الى بيلاروسيا فيما يقول الخبراء
انها الرساله النوويه الاكثر وضوحا منذ
بدايه الحرب الاوكرانيه
لكن على الرغم من كل التكهنات الذائعه حتى
الان فان الولايات المتحده القوه النوويه
العظمى الاخرى ردت بحذر على تصريح بوتين
حيث قال مسؤول كبير في اداره بايدن انه لا
توجد مؤشرات على ان موسكو تخطط لاستخدام
اسلحتها النوويه ما فتح المجال الاستنتاج
ان ما ستنشره روسيا لدى جارتها هي اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه مثل القنابل الصغيره
والرؤوس الحربيه محدوده المدى وطلقات
المدفعيه وكلها تستخدم لتحقيق مكاسب محدده
في ساحه المعركه وليست من نوع القنابل
الذريه التي تتسبب في القضاء على مدن
كامله بزرعها ونسلها